[Musica]
giallo rosa sarà l'impostore questa
volta io no e nemmeno io e tu
sbrighiamoci dobbiamo completare le
tasche prima che l'impostore c elimini o
faccia un sabotaggio al reattore la
nostra missione sara completare tutte le
tasche è scoprire chi è l'impostore
quindi iniziamo a dividersi tu vai in
caffetteria io resto qua in elettrica
circolata qualche test che vuoi fare
tutte queste tu vuoi ha controllato la
navigazione presto sbrighiamo abbiamo
ora cerchiamo le tasche da completare
qua provate a indovinare chi è
l'impostore prima della fine del video
l'unica regola di questo gioco non
dovete spoilerare nei commenti chi è
l'impostore lo scorso video di among us
nella vita reale ha superato i 20 mila
mi piace come promesso ecco la seconda
parte
se anche questo video sopra i 20 mila mi
piace ci sarà anche una terza parte
quindi cari crew mail polizza vediamo se
c'è qualche taste da fare qua in
electric venite ragazzino ho trovato una
tasca che mi sono dimenticata di
chiedervi vi piace il mio nuovo
cappellino il fiore
guardate vediamo che cos'è o no è la
solita a tusk in cui bisogna fare il suo
ipod della card è la task che odio più
di tutti
avete visto anche voi passata un'altra
persona un altro crew meriterà rosso
forse è entrato dopo è molto sospetto
proviamo a seguirlo
è sceso al piano di sotto
cosa starà facendo secondo me e
l'impostore molto strano non c'è nessuno
qua al piano di sotto il che vuol dire
che probabilmente ha usato uno dei 20 ed
è sparito quindi rosso e sicuramente
l'impostore ora faccio questa task e poi
vado premere il bottone per le emergenze
meeting così posso riportarne il celeste
che ci fai qua bene penso di aver
completato questa tastiera un po strana
cioè togliere le foglie dalla navicella
spaziale anche celeste sta venendo come
bravo celeste andiamo vediamo se c'è
qualcuno qua non c'è nessuno rosso il
giallo sono spariti non li ho proprio
visti come definito celeste per un
momento è sparito anche céleste ma ora è
tornato
chi è il sospetto secondo voi
com 08 rosso stato eliminato
ma da chi è stato eliminato
no no no no no no no no sarebbe questo
questo era un nostro fiume non si mangia
non si mangia celeste molto è un aiuto
si è preso un pezzo di rosso celesti
quando il freddo di notte non ti mangia
cosa è successo qui certa mangiato un
pezzo di gotto ce ne starei eliminato
rosso l'estratto conto chi è stato ma di
sicuro ora non sta rosicchiando o no
celeste
questo
112 sopra 48 ed iniqua da bravo essere
da minuto è un nostro compagno meno
almeno posto povero rosso è stato
sgranocchiato da celeste
ma allora sei tu l'impostore di la
verità sei tu l'impostore se lette devo
subito riportare il corpo
siete per forza stati 8 giallo o celeste
no secondo me sei stata proprio tu che
l'hai prima eliminato e poi riportato io
l'ho trovato come basta averne eliminato
io l'ho trovato oggi credo aggiunge
resta che cosa ne pensi perché si è
stato io se sei stato tu cosa hai da
dire in tua difesa
siete entrambi molto morta sospetti non
no voi due siete entrambi molto sospetti
io voto te perché sei sospetta e io voto
celeste perché celeste ha cercato di
mangiare rosso io voto cosa io noto
celeste ciao ragazzi sto cercando perché
testa partiamo se c'è qualcosa qui nei
paraggi
venite ecco ho trovato una task vediamo
sembra ci siano vari numeri
chissà che cosa dovevo fare con questi
numeri ma proviamo 9768 53 succede
niente
forse questa task non funziona
ciao cellette che cosa stai facendo qua
poi davvero facendo una task stai
facendo finta download electrical sembra
che stai realmente facendo una task
bravo no aspetta perché sta scappando
dove vai
non riesco a capire se celeste e
sospetto oppure no eppure stava facendo
una task
tranne il fatto che stava rosicchiando
rosso però non posso sapere se realmente
stato lui ad eliminare rosso chissà cosa
starà facendo giallo adesso o no il
reattore
andiamo subito a salvarlo
cosa ci fate qui se lette e giallo i tre
citati stavo per firmare allenatore non
lo riconosco ma prometto così siete
molto sospetti tutti e due sono sicura
che 8 giallo o celeste e l'impostore no
sto cercando di fermare il recovery
spostati sei bravissima che facciamo il
contrario
senti già allora vedi di finire qualche
task ok io devo andare a finire delle
task in electric tu cerca di fare
qualche tasto qui ok ti si guarda sto
già facendo questa qui scusa
premendo il pulsante sbagliato ok
ragazzi siamo in electric ci mancano
pochissime task da completare e avremmo
vinto noi kromeriz ora certissimi ciao
rosa giallo si hai per caso o sospetti
su qualcuno
vogliamo insospettivi rosso oppure di
celeste ma che stai dicendo rosso è
stato eliminato
basilio è stato eliminato non me ne ero
accorto forse è stato celeste allora hai
per caso sospetti su celeste aspetto
momento morto a 96 spuntato fuori dal
vento qui sotto dalle 20 è sì
[Musica]
il dottore l'ha ridetto si sono proprio
io l'impostore cosa ne hai fatto di the
left di celeste niente ma ti rosso
[Musica]
sì sono stato io sto anche per vincere
allora cosa possiamo fare
magari puoi contare fino a tre prima di
lasciarvi la vittoria 12 è bravissimo
hai chiamato il meeting prima che gli
impostori mi eliminate non rivisto anche
tu se lette l'impostore bravissimo mi ha
salvato celeste io vado stupido giorno
che non sono stato io
celeste dicono che vi sto male e rosa
impostore chester emesse tour ha detto
tutto
lui stava per eliminarmi quindi portano
così avremmo vinto la partita
se avessi fatto un giorno no
[Musica]
ora